when I work with the writer I will train
them through creative integration so
what we will do is we will make them
write to their weakness and hide their
strengths so if I'm right hand I do
everything is that right hand and my
left hand is really uncoordinated
I literally tighten my right hand behind
my black my back for a month and I do
everything is my left hand it's going to
get stronger and more coordinated now
during that month I might spill a lot of
things and be very inefficient but over
time I'll develop my left arm and
coordination the strength then I'll
learn how to integrate the two so for a
conceptual writer they will work
exclusively from the intuitive part they
will learn how to turn off the
conceptual part the conceptual part is
the part that has all these big ideas
and worries about story a lot is all
this anxiety and judgement and turn that
off and teach them how to create from a
pure authentic emotional space now their
writing may not be well structured it
may not be something they're going to
show an agent but they will through that
process their characters will come alive
their dialogue will come alive and
you'll one of the key things when I do
intuitive training is to get you to
think about something in your life where
you feel something very strong and then
your writing when other people read it
they're going to feel what you feel so
you can get people to have the emotional
experience you had when you wrote it
then when I helped you learn how to
discover actual characters and a whole
bunch of training to get to the point
where that's a real person for you then
you can write that person from what
they're feeling and people will feel
that then you can start putting
characters into conflict and it will all
be authentic characters and so that's
the intuitive training and when they get
to the point where their characters and
their dialogue and everything is organic
and authentic as best of the best
writers out there then I'll teach them
how to integrate that back to the
conceptual side so that they all have
the best possible stories and the best
possible characters and then obviously
for and into two writers the opposite
they will turn that part of the brain
off they'll work purely from conceptual
until they're a rockstar and then we'll
integrate and that process it's just so
rewarding to work with writers because
if they come out the other end literally
their agent their manager or their
spouse will say well rida script and say
I love you but you didn't write this
all the time I don't believe you wrote
this because your stories aren't this
crisp and compelling I mean this has all
your great character work but you can't
like who helps you with the stories or
someone will say you don't write
characters that's great I love you I
love your writing but this is like you
know orange is the new black or Maggie I
mean this is just that high level of
characters and it's like it literally is
transformative and then the last thing
I'll say which is really cool about
creative integration is that most
writers occasionally they have these
flow days where everything is just
pouring out of them and it's so great
you're doing your best material and you
love those days and you wish you could
live in those days and then writers have
those days which is the exact opposite
where you're pounding your head against
the wall just trying to get something on
the page and I think for most writers
that I work with they're often somewhere
in between the really great thing about
creative integration is almost all your
days will be flow days because this is
what cause float this is what happens
when a writer is writing there's what
would be best for the story what is the
best thing to make the story move for
the most interesting way and a lot of
writer especially intuitive writers they
don't know the answer and that's really
confusing and frustrating excuse me now
even if you do know the answer and it's
a it's that then of course what would my
character really do and if it's the same
thing and then you ask yourself what do
I most want to write today what gets me
most exciting about writing it's the
same thing all three navigational
systems lying up that's a float that's
when it's all coming out of you it's
your best writing you want to live in
those days when you don't know what the
character would do or you don't know
what's best for the story or you know
but this is what's best for the story
this is what the characters do this is
what you most want to write if all those
are the worst days so the creative
integration does is it allows people to
train and know what the set of suite of
tools what would be best for my story
they'll be able to go to another part
and know what my character really do the
other part and know what they're most
interested in writing and then they'll
have tools to integrate which is to
bring those three things into alignment
and so I can't say that every writing
day it will be
slow day but most of writers are trained
they'll say used to be 10 to 20% for
flow days now it's like 80% and so they
not only does the quality of the writing
greatly improved so does the quantity so
let's say somebody knows you know I'm
very right brained they're very
intuitive right and I resonate with
music and emotions and color right but I
really have trouble connecting the dots
right and staying on task right and I'm
actually speaking personally about
myself so if I know that about myself as
a writer and I know that what's going to
show up on the page is that the story is
going to lack any kind of continuity
probably there's going to be some issues
how do I rein myself in because as a
right brain person that that's one of my
issues I have trouble reining myself
sure
so how would somebody who's so used to
being oh I'm going to go with this
emotion I'm gonna go with this right so
make themselves more linear so it's
different for every writer but generally
speaking what I would probably do if I
was working with you is the first thing
I would say is we're going to turn off
your intuitive side and develop your
conceptual sight so that you're going to
be able to naturally and easily be able
to connect the dots but not only connect
the dots but do it with real strong
stakes and clarity and strong
escalations and you're going to be able
to create as strong of a story as anyone
in the industry and that story in a
sense is is a glass and then we're going
to teach you how to pour your characters
and your dialogue and your emotion and
all that intuitive stuff into that
structure so that now your characters
and your dialogue will be in service of
a super strong story so and then usually
the writers like oh that's exciting I
want to do that how do I do that then I
say okay well here's step one I need to
imagine that we're going to go behind
the barn and take everything that you
love about writing and we're going to
shoot it in the head and that's the
writers like I don't want to do that but
that's what it feels like because what
we need to do is turn off that part of
you that is that dreamy intuitive
emotional connective instinctive part of
you now we're not going to kill that
forever that is such a valuable part of
you but we are literally going to turn
off because here's the thing if it's on
your conceptual brain can't be on they
both can't be on the same time they're
connected by a corpus callosum and just
physiologically speaking they can't be
on the same time it would it would
short-circuit the fight-or-flight
mechanism so we're going to turn this
off and so the training in the beginning
is we are going to be creating simple
stories and then more complex stories
and eventually scripts that there will
be no characters and there'll be no
dialogue and we're literally like going
to be playing with just puppets and we
are going to be doing we're going to I'm
going to drill you day in and day out
week in and week out on exercises for
story logic and for story cutting but so
if I may back up the there's a really
cool class up there called drawing from
the right side of the brain I'm sorry
yeah drawing fire to their brain and
they have w-4 and after pictures they
have these people who are terrible
illustrators they do self-portraits and
you look at it and you're like Butte
I wouldn't even call these stick figures
because I'd be an insult stick figures
these are terrible drawing and then they
have three days later the same person
does their same self-portrait and it's
like this is amazing like how could
someone in three days go from being such
a terrible drawer to such an amazing bar
and so the key is she has broken down
the drawing into five specific skill
sets and one of them is contrast one of
them is shapes and this is the key she
teaches you contrast or she teaches you
shapes completely separate from all the
others so you can't learn shaping if
you're worried about what the picture
looks like if you're worried about it
being a good picture you just learn
shaping you just learn contrast you just
learn color I actually don't know what
the five things are by heart but you
learn all five things in isolation and
then the end should teach you how to
integrate it so that's what we would do
so we would be drilling you on story
logic and you'd have a whole week of
those exercises that they're not real
characters it's not a scripture working
on these are just training exercises
then we're going to drill you on five
weeks of story causality then we're
going to work on logic and clarity and
perspective and then we're going to be
working on escalation then we're going
to be
conceptually strong characters and
moving them and you're going to
ultimately create a story where we don't
know anything about the characters they
have no emotional connection but when
you look down at that story you're going
to say that is a clear beginning middle
end it has a forward momentum and
escalation if that story was populated
with super compelling characters and
dialogue it could be amazing and yours
going to be able to do that over and
over again you probably won't enjoy this
training it probably won't be fun
in fact writers usually complain because
they're like this feels like math and
this is I want to be a writer because I
hate math right when can we do the fun
stuff and it's like you cannot do the
fun stuff until you are an expert at
this
you